-Let's talk about
"Hobbs & Shaw."
This is "Fast & Furious,"
a spin-off.
-Yes.
-First spin-off.
-First spin-off, yes.
So, the pressure's on.
-Yeah.
-And I wanted to make a movie
that if you're a fan of
the "Fast & Furious" movies...
-Whoo!
-You're going to -- Whoo!
You're gonna love
"Hobbs & Shaw."
And if you've never seen
a "Fast & Furious" movie,
then, fingers crossed, you're
gonna love "Hobbs & Shaw."
-You're gonna get into this.
Yeah.
-Yes, yes.
-And who is in it?
Now, it's you and --
-It's myself, Jason Statham.
The second sexiest man alive,
Idris Elba.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-The second. Yeah.
-Yes.
-Hello, I'm the first.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Vanessa Kirby is in it.
-Oh, Vanessa Kirby is great.
-Vanessa Kirby's great.
-But there's like --
It's over-the-top action.
-Over-the-top action.
It is bombastic.
It is a big, big summer movie.
And, also,
what I wanted to do was,
of course, pay attention
and pay homage
to the "Fast & Furious"
universe -- the anchors,
like, fast cars, cool cars,
big action, family element.
But I also want
to have our own identity.
You know?
-Yeah.
-With that then
came all the great comedy.
-Dude, it's really funny.
-And we went out.
We got a few surprises littered.
-I think people
are gonna go crazy.
There's a couple
good cameos in there.
-Couple good cameos.
Setting up the future team.
-You can't say who...?
-I can't say who it is.
No, no, no.
-If I went down the list
of possible cameos...
[ Laughter ]
...and then maybe just judging
by your reaction maybe.
-Just by my reaction.
-Yeah, I mean,
you don't have to say anything.
-I won't say words, then.
-Beyoncé.
[ Laughter ]
Oprah.
Kevin Hart.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
He just makes you smile, huh?
Cardi B.
[ Laughter ]
Ryan Reynolds?
Dude, it's --
I'm gonna say in the movie,
the trash talking
between you and Statham --
-Statham is --
-Jason Statham is --
Dude, you guys rip each other.
-We do. We do.
-It's great!
-And what's great about that,
Like, we discovered
we had this chemistry
in "Fast 8."
-Yeah.
-So then that was the launching
pad for this movie.
And what's great about Jason is,
you know, he is so by-the-book,
and he likes to read what --
he likes to act
what is on the page.
And I do, too.
-Yeah.
-But, you know, like you,
we like to play.
Let's stretch the scene out
a little bit.
-Let's have fun, yeah.
-Let's have fun.
So I get to set,
and I'm like, "Okay, listen.
I'm gonna say something to you.
I'm not gonna tell you
what it is.
Just go with it."
And he's like,
"I don't know, mate."
I'm like, "That's okay."
[ Laughter ]
-That's -- yeah.
That's how he talks.
-"I don't know, mate."
-Yeah, "it's okay, it's okay."
-"I don't think I like it."
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know."
And then I say something
to the effect of,
"Listen, here's the thing.
If I hit you, then --
If I hit you,
and my fist connects,
you'll die."
[ Laughter ]
If I miss,
the wind behind the punch
will give you pneumonia
and your ass will die anyway.
So, it's up to you."
[ Laughter ]
-That's hilarious.
-"So it's up to you."
-But you also wrote
some burns for yourself?
-Oh, and that's what I do, too.
So that's the balance with
Jason Statham or with anybody.
So, if I'm gonna talk trash
in these scenes, and that's --
This is all "Hobbs & Shaw" is,
by the way...
-Yeah.
-...of just this great banter
back and forth,
then I offer up, "And here's
what you could say about me."
So, for example,
I said this on day one.
This was our first day
of shooting.
I said, "Listen."
And it's day one.
"I know -- here's the script."
-Yep.
-"And we're gonna say
what's here.
But, you know, let's --"
-Yeah.
-"Let's play a little bit,
right?"
-Yeah.
-So then I -- then I say --
-Now I'm nervous.
[ Laughter ]
-Then I say --
And this made the movie.
I say, "You know what it is?
Here's exactly
why I don't like you."
And I'm talking
to Jason Statham.
And I say, "'Cause your voice --
there you go.
"'Cause your voice,
you sound like
a prepubescent,
nasally Harry Potter."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then -- so, in order
to get that through, I said,
"But here's what you
could say about me.
You could say,
"Oh, yeah, it's your face.
It's your stupid, big face.
As if God projectile-vomited
right in my eyes."
[ Laughter and applause ]
See? Perfect.
-And he did that?
-And he did it,
and it made the movie,
and crowd goes crazy.
-Oh, I love it.
It's so much fun.
It's gonna be the biggest movie
of the summer.
It is so fun to watch.
Go see it in the theater.
Go see it in IMAX if you can.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's great.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dwayne Johnson in
"Fast & Furious Presents:
Hobbs & Shaw."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Now or never.
-I'm more of a now type of guy.
-On my three.
-Sure.
-One, two, three!
Unh!
-No one tells me what to do.
♪♪
[ Gunshots ]
[ Gunfire ]
[ Grunts ]
♪♪
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dwayne Johnson, everybody!